I am Nancy Damon I am the program
director of the Virginia festival of the
book and this is one of the first
programs and we're so happy to welcome
you here today thank you very much for
coming the virginia festival the book is
in its seventh year it's a put on by the
Virginia Foundation for the Humanities
which is the State Humanities Council of
Virginia it's an annual festival as you
know that celebrates literacy and
reading we have programs all over town
in schools at the University and
practically everywhere you might go home
and find one in your home for all I know
this festival wouldn't be possible
without lots of lots of lots of
wonderful volunteers everybody from the
volunteers who man decides to although
they're not volunteers the people at the
book stores who make this possible and
we just want to thank you for all your
people power hours and hours that went
into this festival we also like to thank
major sponsors the city of
Charlottesville the county of Albemarle
sprint sprint Yellow Pages wmr a radio
station the daily progress one of those
other bookstores sorry
Barnes and Noble US Airways and Wachovia
Bank who contribute a lot of money so
that we can have this free and open to
the public we do ask you to fill out
evaluation forms which the volunteers
have in the back could you please hold
us up those nice salmon-colored forms
they really really help us and we're
actually giving away door prizes this
year including some airline tickets so
it would really behoove you to fill one
out with your name and address and at
this point I'd like to turn the program
over to Anne Kenny from the department
of East Asian Studies the East Asian
Studies program he's going to introduce
our speaker and she is where Dan go
there she is
yay hello we're very happy to have Julie
Chang with us today and I'd like to say
that this talk is also sponsored by the
University of Virginia's East Asia
Centre
and we're particularly thrilled to have
you here because at least some of the
students in the audience are taking a
course on exemplary women in China and
we've decided that you are one of the
examples of a woman in Chinese history
who's taken a stand and who's done some
heroic things and we're thrilled to have
you here and look forward to hearing
your speech thank you thank you that's
very honored to be here I'm really happy
there's a first trip for me to be a
Virginian everything it's very exciting
I did three presentations today so this
is the last time I was at a school it
was wonderful it was wonderful well
let's just start this is this is the
first book I wrote red scarf girl the
picture on the cover was me when I was
12 years old I'm from Shanghai China as
you probably know a lot about China it's
a-you know the Far East it's a huge
country the population of China is the
five times as a population of America as
your China has one quarter of the
population of the world and the shanghai
is the largest city in China it has 14
million people it's huge it's in that
small space
my name is a chilly many people have a
hard time to say my name they often ask
me it's pronounced the G ly or jelly
it's pronounced GE e le e GE actually
it's pretty simple chili I would have to
start from my name why and how I was
named I was born on Chinese New Year a
very special day for Chinese according
to an old Chinese saying a New Year's
baby will have a special
destiny the baby will become either a
king or a beggar I'm sure my parents
didn't like me but to be a beggar they
chose my name very carefully they named
me G Lee in Chinese meaning lucky and
beautiful they hoped that I will be the
happiest girl in the world
well I did turn out to be what they
wanted me to be I was happy I was
healthy and I was quite successful I had
a very loving family my grandmother was
a retired a teacher both parents were
working I have a one brother who is one
year younger than I am and the one
sister who is a younger when you're
younger than my brother at a school I
was one of the best the students I was a
DA 3 Jeong which was equivalent to
student council president in other words
I was a head for all the students in my
school and I participated several art
troops and a one a lot of speech
contests also ever since that was a
second upgrade I started to practice
martial arts and a step by step I was
selected into one of the best teams for
children in Shanghai so everything was
perfect and I was very happy and very
confident that I would have a bright
future in my motherland as long as I
continued to listen and follow our great
leader Chairman Mao well as you probably
know Chairman Mao was the leader for
China since 1949 until his death in 1976
all our lives were with hold to love him
and we did we truly believed heaven and
earth are great but a greater still is
the Communist Party father and mother
are dear but the earth Theo is Chairman
Mao we truly believed what we were told
we were so lucky to live in
socialist the China while two-thirds of
the people around the world were
starving we're dying miserably under
capitalist the country so we felt we
were very lucky to have a chairman ma as
our savior and we were we proud of that
and the until 1966 the cult revolution
started then everything changed I wanted
to show you some slides while while I'm
talking and it's not the most clear
slides you can see but we just have to
bear with that can we turn the lights
off please
this is a my mother and the three of us
I'm the oldest the one this picture was
taken in 1959 so it's over 40 years my
father is a stage actor he worked for
children's theatre all his life the one
on the very right that was my father
playing a pirate you can tell this show
was for children my mother used to be an
actress too
the the first the row the lady sit right
next to the lady holding the flag that
was my mother that picture was taken in
1950 so it's a 51 years old my
grandmother and my father my grandfather
died when my father was only seven years
old so my grandmother raised my father
on her own this was me probably at a
third third grade that time I was in the
team of Shanghai Children's Palace later
I was elected into a better team this is
our home the balcony on the third floor
second from the left that was our home
well talking about home actually it was
only one room it's a one room about 300
square feet big you know talking about
Chinese history and I would like to
mention a little bit the living standard
back then of course this was 30 years
ago and the living standard was pretty
low and the housing was very very tough
especially in the big city like Shanghai
our family actually was considered very
lucky to have that 300 square feets big
room a lot of family of five or six
people there one room could be only 150
square feet big or sometimes even
hundred square feet big probably could
be smaller than your bedroom therefore
people had to build attic in the middle
of the ceiling and the night kids would
climb into the Attic to sleep and they
would use bunk beds or some family
really the room was too small they had
to put a mattress underneath
the table at night so the kid the kids
could have sleep on it well also our
family was considered lucky because we
had our own bathroom we call that a
private bathroom a lot of families they
had to share their bathroom with a
several other families or they did not
have their bathroom they would use a
wooden stool as their toilet that wooden
stool would be put at a corner of the
room and using a curtain to separate
from the room and in the morning you
take it out and then empty it and clean
it then you bring the back so that's how
we lived of course you know no TV no
color TV no black or white TV but we had
a radio almost every family had a radio
for entertainment for news for
everything and we did not have a cars
and wherever we went we rode the
bicycles you saw that a thousand
thousands bicycles in China that was our
main transportation I think even now the
bicycle was still the main
transportation and the other thing we
did not had was private telephone almost
all the families did not have a
telephone at home well we did have a
phone but that phone was shared by
several thousands of the people I show
you how that worked this is our alley
this was considered a good neighborhood
did you see that telephone stein
underneath of the sign it was a small
booth well there was a phone and two
older ladies were working there if
someone called me the lady would take
down all the information who do you want
to talk to and the address and what's
your name what's your return phone
number then she would come all the way
to the back because we live in the back
and she would shouted at me from the
ground since we live on the third floor
she'll call Jeanne you have a phone call
then I would come down to get that a
piece of information I would pay her
three cents for her service then I would
come back all the way to this booth
so whoever called me had to wait for
fifteen or twenty
minutes at the other end and there were
about 1,000 people live in this alley
this film was assured not only by our
ally but several others are wrong our
ally so literally it was shared by
several thousands of people and as you
can imagine you know a lot of time it
was a line and no one was allowed to
talk more than two or three minutes
otherwise people would complain so I
tell people students about this life
they're like mouth was open he said yeah
it must be hard for you no TV you can
talk to your friends hours and hours
that's the life we had and those are the
things we did not have but I want to
show you one thing we had and I promise
you you don't or maybe you did for a
while these are the ration stamps back
then the surprise were very limited so
we had to use ration stamps to purchase
a lot of stuff this particular one is
food ration stem and each one represents
different quantity like the first left
corner that was like a 1 ounce
second one was like half pounds the
third one was 2 ounce and also from
different province we call province to
hear your call state and you have you
know the food ration stamp issue the
from Virginia cannot be used in
California that's why you see so many
different ration stamps and how did this
work if I want to buy a pancake for
example on the street besides money you
had to give money though besides money
you had to give two equivalent to one
ounce of a food ration stamp to purchase
that pancake if you want to buy a bag of
rice 20 pounds besides money you had to
give two equivalent to 20 pounds of food
a ration stamp to buy that bag of rice
and we had a ration stamps for many
things cooking oil sugar beef egg fabric
whether you buy a new cloth from a store
or buy fabric to make clothes you had to
give to that type of Russian stamp to
equip
- how much you want to buy and the
supplies were very limited eggs were
very limited and the most time each
family was only allowed to buy one
pounds or two pounds
eggs per month and the beef was another
thing 30 years in China I never had a
steak never we often had ground beef
stirred with vegetables and the ones in
a great while we would have a big pieces
of a beef like this but each kid was
only allowed to have a to pieces because
if you didn't calculate everything very
carefully you overspend then you had to
wait until next month for new ration
stamps to come well that's a you know
just give you a little bit a background
about the life we had however we did not
complain what we're pretty happy we
thought this was the beautiful life we
had and everyone else had worse life
than we did until 1966 the cult
revolution started well as I said the
cult revolution was launched and the led
by Chairman Mao and he was the savior
for us and by the time the cult
revolution started chairman mao was
worshipped like a god
these are Chairman Mao's buttons every
day every one or the wear one and we
treasured this in a great deal if I
could get a big size or new style Wow
everyone would ndu and we also traded
because this meant so much to us
these are Chairman Mao's works some of
his articles and the poetry he wrote
beautiful poetry by the way and the one
with the portrait that was a Chairman
Mao's quotation they pull out of his
quotation from different speeches
actually I brought a condensed version
this is a real Chairman Mao's quotation
we call this red precious book this was
the most popular book back then because
everyone had to study this every day
it has 270 pages
people could recite the whole thing that
tells you how often how frequent we had
to study this I want to show you how we
started our day every morning if you
were students you would do this at a
school if you were a worker you would do
this at a factory the first thing in the
morning was that everyone had to stand
up facing Jemima's picture we would sing
a song the title of that song was called
the East is read it says the East is red
Sun is rising China has a Chairman Mao
he is creating happiness for everyone he
is the savior for us all there was
second paragraph and the third paragraph
and this song was the most popular sound
back then because every day everyone had
to sing it after we send that sound
everyone would hold this red precious
book and I chanted together like this we
wholeheartedly wish our great leader
great teacher great commander great
helmsman chairman ma long life long life
long life that's how we started our day
we call this morning greetings
a group of farmers from a very remote
area near Vietnam were doing morning
greetings as I described it you can tell
they were holding this red precious book
chanted faith in Jemima's picture before
they went to work all the tools were on
their shoulders doing morning greetings
they even carried a small blackboard
with Jemima's quotation on it when they
went to the rice field so they could
study Chairman Mao's Caucasian during
the breaks a group of red guards dressed
in army uniform and performed on the
streets well red guards were the most
loyal follower of Chairman Mao there
were students from middle schools high
schools and colleges and they danced on
the streets actually we had a name for
this kind of dance it's called royal
dance it was very
generate very rough it would say
something like smash smash smash smash
your dog head if you oppose Gemma mall
they did this to show their loyalty to
Chairman Mao thousands and thousands of
Red Guards traveled to Beijing to see
Gemma mo during that time Gemma mal
allowed to red guards to travel around
the country for free so they waited and
waited at the Chairman's Square for days
when finally Chairman Mao showed up they
were so excited that they cried that
they shouted a slogan
long live Chairman Mao long live
Chairman Mao to them this was a dream
coming true because back then to teach
him mo in person was the biggest wish
for almost everyone now finally they
searched him a more in person at the
first three months of the revolution
Gemma went with chairman square eight
times and received 11 million red cards
actually that's how Chairman Mao started
coach revolution she's third students up
and they were willing to do whatever he
asked them to do when the cult
revolution started school stopped
instead of studying we were doing some
revolutionary tasks to write big cared
poster was one of them we use brush to
write articles after articles on those
big pieces of white paper to attack the
teachers to attacked school leaders to
attack educational systems and after we
wrote it we post it inside of the
classroom when all the classroom walls
were covered we post them in the
playground outside of the building this
picture was taken in Beijing University
you can see how high they had to climb
up in order to post all these big
character posters you can also see this
on the streets you know the street war
and everywhere the big carrot poster was
so common back then
in the next few days
many people rush the two streets to
smash store signs the revolutionary said
well there are a lot of store names
indicating old ideas oh the culture oh
the custom old habit we call that 402
which you were supposed to be eradicated
during a cult revolution so this was a
typical scene the guy was holding an axe
was about to smash this beautiful wooden
store size and all the names for example
I had of a store I lighted a lot called
great prosperity market prosperity
hinted at making money making money was
such a bad thing
so they renamed it to something like
worshipping no market don't stood for
Malta don't let the name of Chema mom a
theatre very close to my house called
piece theater they renamed it to
revolution theater
in just a few days many many stores
signs were smashed new names such as new
China Red Sea loyal forever were written
on red banners hanging over the doorways
as a temporary store size because the
revolutionaries didn't even have the
time to make new signs they had to use
red banners instead not only the store
names were replaced a lot of streets
name were changed this party look
particular one was renamed entire
imperialism Road according to camp
Chinese Communist Party America was the
largest imperialist country back then
this was a Confucius statue and of
course he well he was the most
influential scholar and the philosopher
in Chinese history
but during a cult revolution he was the
target but he had died so many years ago
so they took out his statue dug out of
his eyes dug out his heart and posted a
lot of slogan on his big statue like
this one was saying
number one scoundrel and then they put
him with this a spatula on the truck and
drove it through the streets to
humiliate him just like a humility to
any other human being in the next few
months the Revolution was expanded to
people's clothing
well the revolutionaries claimed there
were still a lot of clothing reflect
reflecting Western bourgeoisie style for
example any pants
if the trouser legs were narrower than
eight inches for women or nine inches
for men were considered unacceptable
I guess jeans were popular here probably
that's why it was so bad in China
therefore the Red Guards went to streets
to check people's clothing literally if
they saw someone pants were tight they
would have stopped you and measure it
but it's so hard to measure a pencil
when it's out
so they invented a new method they would
use an empty beer bottle and try to
stuff in that appear ball to into your
trouser legs if the beer bottle could
not be stuff in that means your trouser
legs were too tight the red guards would
cut it open in front of the spectators
if your leather shoes were too pointed
they would cut it open if your hairdo
was too fashionable they would do
something in this picture a group of
revolutionaries were condemning this
hairdo this was too fashionable actually
we call this airplane style was a little
go forward and going back this was too
fashionable the heading for this the
poster says the open fire twas this
monster head I think we are too high so
we cannot see the first line so open
fire towards this monster head it was a
pretty scary time because you would
never know what's going to happen to you
people were even seriously thinking of
changing the traffic lights so red would
mean gold and green would mean stop -
the revolutionaries red
stood for communism Ament improvement
progress moving forward
why should red means stop we think about
today's sounds so ridiculous but back
then it was a serious issue to discuss
when the revolution continued a lot of a
persecution occurred rich people were
the first one to be attacked the sign
from the husband next says counter
revolutionary capitalist so-and-so I
couldn't read what the crime for this
wife is assigned but you can tell they
put her name upside down and they use
red ink to cross it to indicate this was
an enemy if you look closely you could
see she was kneading on a washboard back
then we did not have a washing machine
so we were using a wooden flat board
with the kind of a sharp edges
you probably had used this when you wash
clothes do you press your clothes
against this sharp edge of the washboard
during a cult revolution the washboard
became common a common punishment tool
they often forced the target to kneel on
this sharp edge of the washboard during
a struggle meeting this struggle meeting
was held two against a bunch of nuns
when the Mary convent was forced to
close in Beijing this is a pretty
typical scene for a struggle meeting the
target would spend in the middle bowing
their heads a lot of time they would
have a big sign hanging from their neck
saying what crime they have committed in
this case because there were nuns so
that's their only crime during that time
religion was forbidden and the masses
would sit around and shouted slogans to
condemn them for their crime he was the
deputy secretary of Shanghai which was a
very high position sort of like I was a
lieutenant governor here and during a
cult revolution he was the target
and not only you know they struggled
against him had big sign also they put
him on the truck and drove him through
the streets to humiliate him he was or
not
army general alive back then we had very
few army generals
alive they made a great contribution to
our country but some of them died and so
we had only handful army generals alive
back then and of course during the
culture evolution he was the target he
was tortured badly during a torture one
of his legs was broken but the
revolutionaries did not stop there they
put him in a crate and carried him to
another struggle meeting many people
were killed many people killed
themselves because they couldn't stand
the torture and humiliation the
gentleman on the right was a very famous
Peking Opera actor he was beaten to
death the gentleman on the left was the
first Chinese who won world ping-pong
championship for China in 1959 so he was
a hero for a while but when the cult
revolution started he was accused of
being a spy he was tortured he was
beaten badly
finally he couldn't take it anymore he
hanged himself from a tree at age of 31
in his last letter he said I'm innocent
my reputation is more important than my
life
he killed himself
this gentleman's name was allowed sure
he was one of the most respected and
well-known playwright and novelist
actually he was called shakes
Shakespeare of China because many of his
plays are still very popular to today
when the cult revolution started he was
very sick he was hospitalized the very
first day he came out of hospital and
went back to his work unit immediately
he was put under several struggle
meetings not only they tortured him they
beat him they also shaved his hair into
an in young hairdo that means they only
shaved half of his hair and leave the
other half this was the worst
humiliation for any Chinese they beat
him and tortured him he fainted several
times but every time he woke up they
dragged him to another struggle meeting
they did not stop torturing him until
midnight that very first day he came out
of hospital then they told him go home
now come back tomorrow we continued he
never came back he went to a lake at a
suburb of Beijing and I said er the
whole night in the morning he jumped
into the lake and the drown himself
later we found out actually at that time
he was considered a Nobel Prize winner
when the news arrived China they found
that he was dead already so they give
this prize to someone else there were so
many deaths but if anyone dared to
question what's going on why they could
be killed very easily this a young lady
was a very brave communist party member
that's her daughter I remember that time
she was 11 years old
she saw the situation she couldn't
understand so she wrote the letters to
the government central government think
about it she didn't do anything harmful
she didn't kill anybody
she didn't bomb any places but writing
letters to your own government which was
supposed to protect you but even that
was too much she was put in prison
immediately her husband was forced to
divorce her they beat her they tortured
her but she was so determined she
continued to write letters from the jail
finally she was executed the night
before her execution they cut her vocal
cord
they cut her vocal cord to prevent her
from ennis from saying anything on her
way to the execution ground I can tell
you many stories many inhumane many
cruel stories like this according to
different statistics 1 million people to
4 million people died and 10 million
people were injured during this culture
evolution can we turn the lights back on
thank you so this is sort of like a
background of culture evolution what
happened to my family and what happened
to me we can turn the lights up when the
cult revolution started just like
millions and millions other Chinese
people I was very excited I thought wow
this is great for our country so I
participated in thews a Stickley but a
very soon I found a terrible truth my
grandfather's family had been rich my
grandfather was a land owner plus a
capitalist it did not matter that he had
died 30 years ago when my father was
only 7 because land owner was the enemy
of the country our family's background
was Kindle forever in just a few months
I had gone from being an outstanding
student to being an outcast I was kicked
out of the team I was in we children
were bullied by our classmates and thus
neighborhood kids
my father was put under investigation
and labeled as one of so-called ghosts
and monsters and he and my mother were
so worried they had to secretly burn a
lot of family photos and repainted my
grandmother's
beautiful wedding leather trunk fall of
them to black so they would be less
noticeable things God the worse and the
worse in 1968 two years since the cult
revolution started my father was
detained that means he was not allowed
to leave the theater ground where he
worked for months we were not allowed to
visit him we did not know what they were
doing to him sometimes we didn't even
know whether he was alive or dead
because several people from his a
theater were beaten to death and another
lady jumped out the window to kill
herself at the meantime my mother was
very sick she often passed out but she
was not allowed to have sick leave she
was told to lie down at the back of the
store where she worked if she couldn't
stand up my grandmother who was 74 years
old that year she was forced to sweep
our neighborhood streets twice a day as
a punishment of being a land owners
Widow the revolutionaries came to our
house and ransacked the house twice and
they took almost everything we had we
ended up with no tables no chairs no
beds even when the winter came we had to
put a straw on the floor as our bed my
my brother found a small packing crate
that packing crate became the closet for
the few clothes we had left the lid lid
of the packing crate laid across two
benches became our table one day the
revolutionaries from my father's theater
came to my school instead of my teachers
in in front of my teachers and the
school leaders they told me they want me
to denounce my father in a struggle
meeting you have seen what a struggle
made him look like
struggle meeting would include a lot of
people from the theatres in Shanghai in
that struggle meeting my father was
supposed to stand on stage two bowing
his head having a big sign hanging from
his neck saying he was monster and I was
supposed to stand on stage two facing
thousands of people to condemn him for
his crime the revolutionaries made it
very clear to me if I refused to do so I
had to sacrifice my future in the land I
loved so much after they left I was in
such a despair because I didn't know
what to do I couldn't tell my mother and
my grandmother because they were black
they had their problems too
and I did not want to tell my brother
and sister because they were younger I
felt like I want to protect them so I
had nobody nobody I could talk about I
don't know how but I remember I was
standing in this very narrow passenger
way between the schoolyard walk and the
school building walk the concrete walls
were very tall were kind of cold
they learned over me and I closed my
eyes I saw my father in my imagination
of course he lowered his head but he
looked up at me helplessly when he saw I
had to follow the chant down with 1000
is my father's name and that you had to
follow a chant in any struggle meetings
when my father's thought that tears was
rolling on his face I did not dare to
think anymore
I asked heaven what should I do there
was no answer
except a slow drizzle was falling that
year I was 14 I was so horrified I
couldn't even cry well
that's the main story of my book and I'm
sure you can find a lot of details from
the book and many many people ask me why
I wrote this book
you know after 30 years there are two
reasons one obvious reason is that I
don't want people to forget about this
dark period of time I feel we experience
somehow like Holocaust as well millions
of people died and I truly believe to
remember it and to talk about it is the
only way to prevent it from happening
again
so that's my first the reason and then
there's the second reason for me to
write this book sixteen years ago when I
came to United States I was shocked by
the beautiful life American children had
and I said to myself wow they had they
have huge houses nice cars tons of toys
countless books they even have school
buses to pick them up every day they are
so lucky they have everything you can
imagine so I thought if I shared my
story with them maybe they will
appreciate their life more you know not
take things for granted
so that was my original intention but
through the years I found that's not the
whole picture
American children have their problems a
lot of family problems like single
parents or sometimes you know abusive
parents even at the schools they are
facing a lot of pressures peer
pressure's related to drugs sex violence
even school shooting which we did not
have to deal with back then so I
realized wow whether that a little
chilly in 60s in China or little
Michelle or David in 90s in United
States we do have something in common we
all have to deal with a lot of
difficulties in our life
we all have to face a lot of pressures
in our lives we all have to make a lot
of decisions in our lives so I often
tell students my picks the wish for you
if you've ever read my book is that you
can gain some courage to use your own
brain to follow your own heart not to
simply due to the pressure and make some
good decisions then I will be very
gratified for writing this book thank
you
questions yes I still go back to China
very often I think well I started a
small company called east-west exchange
to promote the cultural exchanges
between China and America that's the
reason I go back quite often actually I
was there in December to do more
researches for another book I'm writing
my book has been translated into five
foreign languages but not in Chinese the
reason for that is that although Chinese
government announced the cult revolution
was a national disaster but they don't
encourage people to talk about it well
for a while we had a lot of literature
and film and you know about the cult
revolution so we call we call it wound
literature for a while after the cult
revolution but somehow the government
said okay let's stop doing that we have
to move forward so don't talk about it
anymore
that's why you know as it's not
encouraged that therefore my book was
not translated into Chinese I don't
expect it will be published in China
anyway but so far I have no trouble to
go back to China yes
are able did I able to leave China well
in early 80s America starts to open the
door to people from China as a students
so I came as a student although I had a
degree in China but I continued to you
know further my study and I went to
University of Hawaii yesterday the hotel
management and that's the only way I
mean probably that's the most possible
way for people to come to this country
yes no just the drama not the Peking
Opera Peking Opera you had to sing and
do a lot of martial arts he was just the
drama actor
as a child to traditional Chinese
stories and if there are any heroes or
figures in Chinese history that helped
you or that served as role models for
you to panel your behavior
aha that's pretty interesting question
well certainly I have you know read a
lot about heroes and we particularly had
a lot of revolutionary heroes like a
little girl she died at age of 14 and
the Chairman Mao wrote you know was
praised her for her death and many many
heroes how they give their life to save
the China
the problem here is during that time
everyone was very confused you know if
you are against the Japanese invaders or
American invader it's a lot easier for
us and we know we have to fight with
them but the problem is that we were
brainwashed so the government of the
Communist Party told us we had to put
countries interest first people's
interests first before your family your
personal interest so what they told us
was if your parents were enemy of the
country then you had to break up with
them we buy that we agreed totally
because yes the country is more
important if my father was the enemy of
the country yes I would break up with
him and naturally when they came to my
school and told me asked me to denounce
him they also said that well you might
think this was very hard to do but if
you said if your attitude the right it's
not hard they actually gave me the
example the party secretary in my
father's theater who was the highest
level authority and of course during the
culture ablution she was target and they
had her daughter come to denounce her
the daughter actually came and she was
so angry about her mother because she
didn't listen to Chairman Mao so she
actually slapped her on the stage and
because that's what they told me I
didn't see it they said because she was
in so much' forth she ended spin her
body like this so that's the example
they gave to me is he she did a great
job because she said her attitude right
if you realize your father was the enemy
of the country and then you had no
problem to denounce him my problem
one is our family was very very close
and the other problem was I never heard
anything or see anything my father did
which was against the chairman ma and in
the country they were very careful you
know and I thought that they loved
Chairman Mao as much as I did so I
couldn't think of anything to denounce
them and and our family were very very
close I always believed that they loved
hmmm oh so that's why I couldn't do it
you know I just told myself no I'm I'm
not doing so it's a little different
from the hero because hero you know you
know your enemy and and then host your
friends but in this case many people
were so confused that's why some kids
did announce their parents which was a
very sad situation and I don't think we
should blame those kids because they
were so confused they were brainwashed
yes if you didn't do it were you
punished in any if I didn't do it was I
punished well what they said to me is a
few didn't do it we were punished you
and also would bring your brother sister
from the school and we would do it
together
but what happens I didn't report to them
you know a few days I suppose but I
didn't but it's very coincident at that
time they just got a permission from
higher authority my father was very
stubborn he was in in detect was
detained for several months and he often
said no I didn't do anything wrong and
they were so upset so they really want
to nail him down and that's why they
came to my school but at the meantime
they reported it to a high authority so
after they came to me and they got
permission from high authority and
recategorize my father as a land owner
you know before my father's father was a
land owner which was enemy but my father
was not but they used all the materials
saying that when he was 18 years old he
went to university in Shanghai sejong's
University and that time he was using
landlord's money to support himself and
18 he was an adult
therefore he recategorize as a landlord
land owner and of course he was we call
a dead tiger you know its enemy already
and that they didn't even need my
testimony so they sent him to
countryside for labour for another eight
eight nine months and after that he was
allowed to come home but it was doing
janitor work for several several years
and until 99 1980 all his charges were
dropped
actually they appointed him as the vice
president of the children theater but
from 1966 to ninety eighty how many
people can have 14 years you know yeah
we my father loves acting you know
acting yes his love and he but in China
because all those political movement he
was not allowed to given a lot of
important roles but so fortunately he
started to participate American movies
they are all live here in in Seattle
area and he started from like last
emperor he was in that movie and the red
corner and he had many movies that last
year he had a Shanghai noon he plays the
uncle of Jackie Chan and also another
movie called the Romeo Must Die you know
he was the play some important arose and
we were so happy for him because you
know after so many years finally he has
an opportunity to do something he loves
he's still acting the end next month he
is going to Singapore for another
something I don't even know so that's a
that's my father and I will
we are very grateful for that actually
all my family members moved here except
my grandmother who passed away in 1992
at age of 98 everyone else is here my
sister is also a math teacher at a
community college and my brother works
for a travel agency and my parents enjoy
their grandsons so really we all
survived amazingly yes yes
how much children good question the
question is that how much people are
really talking about the cult revolution
in China and also how much they were
taught at a school about the culture
problem revolution it's very interesting
I didn't realize this before well one
thing is we never sit down to compare
our notes within our family and I never
thought about it you know until after I
wrote my book and my sister and all my
father told me more stories about what
happened to them because these are the
stories I remembered and what happened
to my sister and actually my father had
some other horrible experiences in his a
theatre I did not know and we never
talked about it
and I after the book was published and
the people asked me this question I have
Chinese friends they don't want to talk
about the culture ablution that was so
true and I noticed that and people don't
like to talk about it I'm not so sure
why actually this is not unusual people
don't talk about it in China and yes the
cult revolution was written in the
textbook as our history and the thought
at school but I don't think they give
that much detail what had happened
actually young people in China don't
know too much about it I have a Chinese
who called me although he came to me to
say thank you for writing this book
because that's exactly what I want to
tell my daughter and they should
remember it I'm not sure why I think
it's a shameful or some experiences but
like Holocaust the people talk so often
maybe we don't have enough time maybe 20
30 years of 50 years later people would
start to talk about it maybe now is the
soul so painful I talked to my friend
girlfriend she said that there are
moments she couldn't think about she had
to shut down her mother was struggled
against on the street downstairs of
their window you know she
we're sitting here was just like her her
heart was tightened she couldn't think
about it maybe this was still very fresh
and also maybe it was a shameful to talk
about it so it's very interesting
question but I noticed that that's true
Chinese don't like to talk about it
other questions um well it's so
different now China has changed so much
this happened in 1966 so it's like over
30 years ago
definitely China has opened up a lot no
question about living standard has
improved so much
Shanghai especially you you know I was
having dinner with the friends on the
top of the hotel and they look at the
city lights you could not tell this is a
Shanghai or San Francisco
it's very westernized I brought groups
to China every time they came to me said
this is amazing I never see a city is
changing so much and construction
everywhere
yes living standard has improved a lot
a color TV telephone computer was common
I think people have more freedoms now
because people dare to mark our
president or our leaders I was in the
big bus with a group of Westerners
actually they most of them from Virginia
a group of a chiropractors and the tour
guys start to make fun on the prime
minister and all those Westerners turned
back to me I was sitting in the back
seat is he okay then they thought he
would be arrested I said I guess so if
you've done this every day and I was in
the car a taxi when Tong Xiao Qing died
you know I was the asking the taxi
driver I often like to talk to them and
I said hey how come you don't cry
remember when the Chairman Mao died the
whole country cried for days he said
something like what have you been you
know why should we cry you know the
attitude people do have a more freedom
definitely back then if you drop Jimmy
mouse button and you broke it you
Meissen in jail you might be sent in
jail you know
and if you've shouting slogan and you
made a mistake you would be
counter-revolutionary no question about
that freedom is much much more but of
course it's not as free as this country
that's for sure and I have a very mixed
feeling about it you know what we're
talking chairman square democracy yes
that's wonderful but on the other hand
China is a such a huge country and that
many many problems many errors are very
very poor we have a lot of minorities
problems so if you don't you're not
doing things very carefully if go wild
it could be out of control and we don't
want to see China follow Soviet Union's
footstep because I personally feel
people were the one to suffer the most
if you economy is not doing well people
were the one to suffer so that's my
feeling
in China I think it's opening up
economically it's really going very
rapidly but politically I hope the
freedom will come little by little
gradually you know with the Chinese
people are no longer isolated the
Internet and the computer everyone knows
what knows was going on at the other
side of the world so I think a political
freedom is welcomed eventually but on
the other hand I'm a little concerned
about losing social values because in
old days although we had very little
material but I felt very rich because we
talked about one book one movie for
hours and hours with my friend with just
grass a cup of tea in an act
we enjoyed so much we never fell we were
poor but now people had a lot more
material stuff but they don't care those
things anymore they are caring for money
and I was interviewing a friend of mine
in December in the middle of the
interview she took out those small
devices to see her stock price and she
tell she told me can I stop for a while
I want to make a call to sell my stock
and it's not very unique because many
friends of mine they are doing stocks so
stock is such a hot topic you know in
China which is ok but I don't like to
see they are losing interest on
something else I was talking to them
about oh you know which area was the
poorest area the kids didn't have money
to go to school I'm thinking you know in
run in the long run maybe we can do
something to send the money back they
told me the stuff you are thinking we
don't think anymore you know we're we're
too busy because you can have second job
third job to make more money my time we
did not we couldn't so just the one job
and that's it and we had a plenty time
to think about literature music and
whatever the spiritual things but now
people are so focused on making money
and I am little concerned because I just
hope they don't lose some values which
are very good while they are gaining
some other benefit of the reform
yes the last day what's my opinion about
Chairman Mao now you know about him
right I well I used to worship Him I
used to think he was perfect in 1976
after he died we start to see articles
on the newspapers saying that actually
one of them one of the important reason
for him to launch this coach revolution
was a personal power struggle and he was
a threatened by gaining power of another
leader and of course he might have other
motive but that was one of them and I
was a shocked I was shocked I think at
that moment my political belief
collapsed because I all my life I
trusted him I believed him how can him
manipulated the whole country for his
personal sake I couldn't believe it
because he always told us to put
people's into the first the country's
interest the first but now I look at him
as a human being I think he did some
good things for China and also some bad
things for China it's much easier for me
to accept him as a human being before
was a god he wasn't God he was he was
not perfect and I was very disappointed
I think now I'm I'm thinking him a more
like human being yes the he you know
he's bringing the person by the way but
he made some major mistakes which caused
China a lot of damage and the pain so I
think a lot of people probably have the
similar view like me but again this is
my personal view and I see your question
yes
what was the good things to market for
China
you know before 1949 China was the
ruined by nationalism the coming down
and at that moment the China was really
in a bad shape and the Chairman Mao
United China and we called liberation so
Chinese Communist Party took over for a
while I think people were very happy the
morale was very high at least according
to the people I talked about so that was
very good thing for China he is for the
first time China stood up that's what he
announced on the chairmen gate in 1949 I
think October first we have a new China
now Chinese people stand up and we we
were proud of to be a Chinese so that's
the things and the Chairman Mao has a
very has a vision you know how we can
progress how we can achieve actually
China has achieved a lot of things but I
think he was too optimistic or too
ambitious
the slogan back then was 15 years we
would catch up a Brit British and 20
years we'll catch up America that's
impossible and he liked to hear that was
possible that's why people start to lie
to in order to please him and we had you
know so many political movement but also
I think since 50s and he started a lot
of a political movement which was very
very hard very hard and there's very
crew and he kind of when you had a power
tend to be a dictator you know you just
want more power and more power I think
of from that time on and he really you
know just changed or he did something
which is not very good for China
like to ask more questions you can
approach the podium here and then talk
to James Young and we'd like to thank
you now thank you
thank you so much